- [Instructor] A sociologist
studying fertility
in France and Switzerland wanted to test
if there was a difference in
the average number of babies
women in each country have.
The sociologist obtained
a random sample of women
from each country.
Here are the results of their test.
So you can see a 100-person
sample from France,
a 100-person sample from Switzerland.
They actually don't have
to be the same sample size.
We have our sample means, our
sample standard deviations.
You have the standard error of the mean,
which for each sample
would be our estimate
of the standard deviation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample mean.
And here it says t test for the means
of these different
populations being different.
And just to make sure we
can make sense of this,
let's just remind
ourselves what's going on.
The null hypothesis is
that there's no difference
in the mean number of babies
that women in France have
versus the mean number of babies
that women in Switzerland have.
That would be our null hypothesis,
the no news here hypothesis.
And our alternative would
be that they are different.
And that's what we have right over here.
It's a t test to see if we have evidence
that would suggest our
alternative hypothesis.
And so what we do is we
assume the null hypothesis.
From that you're able to
calculate a t-statistic,
and then from that t-statistic
and the degrees of freedom,
you are able to calculate a p-value.
And if that p-value is below
your significance level,
then you'd say hey this was
pretty unlikely scenario,
let me reject the null hypothesis,
which would suggest the alternative.
But if your p-value is greater
than your significance level,
then you would fail to
reject your null hypothesis,
and so you would not
have sufficient evidence
to conclude the alternative.
So what's going on over here?
You really just have to compare this value
to this value.
It says at the alpha is equal
to 0.05 level of significance,
is there sufficient evidence to conclude
that there is a difference in
the average number of babies
women in each country have?
Well we can see that our p-value, 0.13,
is greater than our alpha value, 0.05.
And so because of that,
we fail to reject
our null hypothesis.
And to answer their question,
no there is not sufficient evidence
to conclude that there is a difference.
There's not sufficient evidence to reject
the null hypothesis and
suggest the alternative.